>>Hi YouTube. I'm Salman bin Hamad from Bahrain.
I'd just like to answer the Davos question.
What is the one thing that companies, business,
governments, and individuals can do to make
the world a better place in 2008? I thought
about this a lot. And really I think that
in this time of uncertainly that we live being
open to one another is the biggest thing that
we can do to make this world a better place.
Like sharing ideas, as we are doing here.
By listening to one another, and by investing
in new people, techonologies, and companies.
I believe we can do a lot. I have heard some
fantastic ideas regarding climate change.
Heard some fantastic ideas regarding energy
dependence. And I have heard many fantastic
ideas regarding water that have been shared,
communicated, and transmitted across the globe.
So while many in this world today are calling
for the closure of borders, the increase of
protection for either products or people.
The world has always been at it's best when
it has been open to itself. Thank You very
much.